ван [ __ ] вона брук ви голодним стик тону
полігамна води не нових санкцій проти
росії вул вапно з сирію в і дусі
добрим і цієї мережі та позиції ти змінила
свою душу заради чого вселяєш ламай не я
не зради у свою думку олег бачатої вина
у сирі та закінченого скільки росія по
суті з ніхто вала дипломатичним
рішенням на корінь
весь когось і т.п. Росія спочила нитки його
ти так звання мирні переговори
адже пресвятого війна проти амір
кованих сил за кимчі на
я поважаю росії по ви нарощувати
відомі ще не до 3 мани міжнародних
правових норм за тебе у мене мирних
переговорів і стос ворог увала інтересів
всіх турин даної фарби та ґрунти для
нирок у давай рядкових наважилися і ж
белявський
трам від сам створить коже шоу видує 6
знято санкції проти Росії в обмін на
скручування ядерних обраний я вам так від
ford не спочатку за виглядом то україну
Росії в обмін на скоро навчання р-ф і
частий на ядерному арсеналі гадаю такого
року безглуздо
забув про апарат з продажу свободи in
шуй україни мені будете до вас просто
регати за перебігом дебату в американському
сенаті все в приводі прикладом що
позначаться на тури коркарі маками конфлікт
віддати sqlite і очевидно а ви чим
а essence знята позбавляти остигання санкції в
обмін на скручування ядерних збій тієї так
і прозвучало вперше не санте в цій
готові всі були ви напередодні мінські
домовленості і ми можемо і зняті
санкції краща кам'яного року буду ви
канону ланцюга на оскар дуже ядерних у
збрей мої but i взаємним рішенням
ядерних держав
вона залишає інж україна з-під
носа ліги на the country